- Michel Pronovost apprécie
Immunosupprimé, il peut profiter
de la nature loin des foules
et de la COVID.
MICHEL PRONOVOST
- Si j'attrappe la COVID
avec mon système immunitaire
déficienue
d'en mourir, en fait.
- Parce que, même vaccinées,
bon nombre de persemeurent
moins bien ou pas du tout
protégéee virus.
L'abolition du port du masque
dans les lieux publics au Québec
génère personnes comme Michel.
- Les gens pensent que
la pandémie est finie,
Je vais me sentir moins
protégé lorsque
le masque était obligatoire.
- L'Association des patients
immunodéficients du Québec
espère que la population sera
bienveiln'ont pan'ont pan'ont p.
GENEVIÈVE SOLOMON, dg, Ass.
patients immunodéficients, Qc
- On veut surtout pas que
juger, se fassent ostraciser,
se fassent mettre de côté.
On souhaite aussi que
des personnes qui auront
le portent.
- C'est un milieu de soins
et qui dit "soins"
- L'Ordre des pharmaciens
encourage d'ailleurs les cli
à le porter en succursale,
puisqu'on y retrouve
BERTRAND BOLDUC, président,
Ordre des pharmacis pharmacis pc
- On s'est tous mis ensemble.
On s'est dit : comment on peuti,
nos patients qui viennent chez
nous d'anous d'anous d'anous d's
en pharmacie aussi
parce qu'une contaminatione d'un
employé, ça a des effetscatastr.
- Cet infectiologue
microbiologiste méanté des pants
à risque devraient primer.
Dr DONALD VINH, infectiologue,
microbiologiste médical
- Le porun inconun inconun inco,
mais, quand on rentre dans
un endroit fermé, l'inconvénient
est temporaire, mais, dans
la vie de quelqu'un d'autre.
- Le Dr Vinh souligne
que le masque est un outil
les personnes vulnérables comme
celles atteintes d'insuffisances
cardiaque ou renale, les femmes
les immunosupprimées.
- Ici Valérie-Micaela Bain,